everyone so just a quick update the new
thinking book has sold out but there'll
be more stock by next week welcome to
another cold fusion video one of the
most important and fundamental
technologies which most people take for
granted are batteries without batteries
some of the most common technology
couldn't exist such as mobile phones
laptops electric scooters and even the
12-volt batteries that run the
electronics in a regular car in 2019
battery technology is finally starting
to move and in this video we'll see how
a new industry is emerging from a recent
wave of development you are watching
told even TV so batteries are thought to
have been used for thousands of years
with the earliest discoveries being the
Baghdad batteries believed to be roughly
2,000 years old
however the invention of the battery
wasn't recognized until 1800s when
Alessandro Volta debuted his zinc copper
battery in recent times the battery has
become crucial to technological
advancement batteries have also allowed
aircraft to go electric you can check
out my previous video on electric planes
if he interested to see how this all
works the link will be in the
description
the main limiting factors from modern
batteries are they cost size and storage
capacity over the last decade the
so-called breakthroughs were announced
many times but fell short of their
promises that's not to say that they
haven't been improvements for example
Tesla's battery cost has been cut in
half and capacity increased by 60%
between 2008 and 2015 it's also reported
that between 2012 and 2017 general
battery cell prices fell by 70% however
despite the progress batteries are often
a limiting factor of new technology and
by that sentiment they must improve that
is easily said but improving the
technology is hardest to do particularly
in finding appropriate materials
one issue with renewable energy is
storage electricity can be generated by
renewable sources but the production by
these sources don't coincide with the
electrical demand of the population for
example in solar the Sun sets just as
the electricity demand increases when
people come home from work better
batteries will make renewables able to
supply more of the electricity demand
even if the source isn't live MIT
professor Don Sadoway
is trying to do just that patenting a
battery to run entire neighborhoods the
company developing the technology is
called Ambree and even has Bill Gates as
an investor what separates Ambree
batteries from the rest is that it is
the only battery where all three active
components are in liquid form both the
electrodes the terminals are liquid as
well as the Molson solution between them
as a result the battery has a low cost
and a long lifespan Tesla is also aiming
to solve the same problem with a neem
giant battery storage facility in
California is expected to debut in the
near future
the company has already solved South
Australia's blackout issues by
installing their battery facilities in
under 90 days the Tesla battery pack was
a massive success and performed well
possessing the ability to supply a
hundred megawatts of power in just 140
milliseconds the energy prices for on
current demand response services went
down 90% in the first 4 months of
operation furthermore the state saved 35
million dollars in that same 4 month
period the state's premier unveiled the
giant battery which is powered by nearby
wind farm Australia is a major exporter
of coal and is considered one of the
world's worst greenhouse gas polluters a
freak storm last year caused a statewide
blackout highlighting the unreliable
supply of electricity the billionaire
business tycoon Elon Musk offered to
build the battery it's a an exciting
development electricity storage has kind
of been the holy grail for the whole
power business for 200 years now wind
and solar produced their electricity
when they want not necessarily when we
want and so some way of storing the
excess that they're producing has been
something we've looked for for many
years
the horns del power reserve or Tesla big
battery has been mocked by critics since
day one by all means have the world's
biggest battery have the world's biggest
banana I have the world's biggest prawn
like we have on the roadside along the
highways around the country but that's
not solving the problem the naysayers
said it was a waste of money
but this big battery is already playing
a key role in stabilizing the grid and
it's doing so with a speed precision and
agility that's never been seen before
this is the market operators instruction
this is the response of a conventional
power station the battery is far swifter
and more accurate while undercutting the
price big power generators charge for
these frequency control services it's
basically providing much-needed
competition to a very concentrated
segment of the electricity market and
where fame you had quite pleasantly
surprised and would encourage more of
this technology into the grid it's
coming this is proof that maybe it's
time to stop laughing at the concept of
batteries powering an electrical grid so
it's clear that things suddenly seem to
be changing but why what caused all of
this to happen surprisingly it all
starts with an individual cell small
enough to fit in the palm of your hand
these are the fundamental building
blocks of the massive utility batteries
powering cities Elon Musk and his team
at Tesla saw a unique business
opportunity that opened up due to
advancing technology you see all they
had to do was build an efficient cheap
battery cell and scale it up it goes
something like this
a single battery cell powers something
like a vaporizer a few order of
magnitude more cells powers a car a few
orders of magnitude above that powers a
town and you get the point batteries
have only just reached the point to make
all of this possible it's such a simple
concept but it's changing the world
to pull this all off Tesla needs to make
a lot of batteries and the gigafactory
one of the biggest buildings on earth
was built to do it the company is said
to be the largest battery maker in the
world as battery technologies continue
to improve who need drastically less
batteries to achieve the same scalable
power it's all pretty cool but even more
exciting is the fact that these battery
projects are coming online all around
the world today we've already deployed
battery systems in 16 countries around
the globe we've got some of the largest
systems existing in places like Arizona
California Hawaii New York coming online
but other places as well the United
Kingdom Australia Japan around the world
of course battery technology would also
mean that electric vehicles could become
more commonplace in order to achieve
better batteries and v's China has
implemented a policy to provide more
subsidies to manufacturers of longer
range EVs
China will subsequently pull back the
subsidies on companies that are not
producing as long-range batteries as
their competitors
[Music]
currently lithium-ion batteries are the
king of battery technology here lithium
atoms are stored inside of graphite
layers inside a cell
the lithium atoms lose and regain
electrons providing the electrical
output SIL and nano technologies is a
company based in California that's
trying to get that breakthrough in
lithium ion technology they intend to
use microscopic silicon particles to
store the lithium inside the battery
their CEO Jean Berta Kazuki was quoted
saying an atom of silicon can store
about 20 times more lithium and atoms of
carbon essentially it takes fewer atoms
to store the lithium so you can have a
smaller volume of materials during the
same amount of energy in quite many
companies and research laboratories are
looking into this technology but what
says still our part is that they claim
to have solved the expansion problem
this arises as silicon expands and
damages the battery wood leads charged
with this hurdle being overcome a new
door has been opened
the new batteries perform up to 40%
better and charge up to nine times as
fast because of the reduced thickness of
the anode Silla have received 17 million
dollars from investors including Samsung
and I said to launch their products in
2019 they're able to do this so quickly
because they're using existing battery
manufacturing techniques and have
working sellable batteries already
research into aluminium iron batteries
have been conducted for several years
now it promises to be safer and cheaper
than lithium iron lithium ion batteries
have a tendency to explode or catch fire
if damaged you may recall the samsung
galaxy note 7 debacle of 2016 aluminum
ion batteries don't react in the same
way and can even have a hole drilled
into them and still keep running the
cost of the battery in comparison to
lithium-ion is also much cheaper as
aluminium is the third most abundant
element taking up 8.1% of the Earth's
crust researchers at Stanford and the
University of New South Wales have both
said that this is promising technology
but still is in the early days in terms
of development and commercial viability
with 3.4 million AV batteries expected
to be produced by 2025 what happens to
these batteries after we're done with
them well in the case of electric cars
the batteries have a life of ten years
after being taken out from the chassis
of the car they can be used for anything
from powering car charging stations to
storing energy for homes currently
there's a joint effort to keep batteries
out of landfill here's a chart of where
used electric car batteries are being
implemented around the world after a
decade
these batteries raw materials can then
be recycled
so let's do a recap is there currently
battery prices have fallen 70 percent
since 2012 and Tesla's battery capacity
has increased 60% from 2008 we have a
liquid battery is set to power entire
neighbourhoods Tesla's utility batteries
are already proving practical for
off-peak energy storage and solving
blackout issues and drastically reducing
cost
lithium silicon batteries coming later
this year that perform 40 percent better
and charge much faster and research into
aluminium iron batteries intensifying
with such considerable demand for
batteries the monetary incentive now
exists to spawn a new wave of battery
development for example Toyota has 233
patents and has invested 14 billion
dollars into commercializing a new solar
state battery for the early 2020s the
company is so serious they're dedicating
200 employees to advancing this
technology let's wrap this video up by
seeing why this time is different there
are countless other projects and types
of batteries being developed such as
vanadium redox lithium air fluoride ion
and the list goes on and herein lies a
fundamental truth of the progress of
battery technology previous to the last
decade there wasn't a strong financial
incentive to improve battery technology
now that electric cars and better a
utility storage are proving to have a
definite potential for a viable
large-scale market everyone is rushing
to create the best tech and sell it it
all comes down to the profit in the end
we all win 10 years ago people didn't
even believe decent electric cars were
possible and established car
manufacturers weren't taking them
seriously until 2018 a battery
revolution is coming and this time it's
different
but for now lithium iron reigned supreme
and the demand will not stop even in
Western Australia where I live there's a
new lithium mining boom caused by this
new technological gold rush perhaps the
future of the electrical grid will be a
combination of renewable energy sources
stored in batteries and clean energy as
assets age out old power plants old
transmission lines and things have to be
replaced what we're finding is batteries
and large format systems are just a
better way to rebuild that
structure and substitute in some cases
for jobs we did with transmission lines
in other cases they substitute for jobs
we did with power generators that's more
compact that fits in urban areas where
we can't build power plants today then
it allows our grids to be flexible and
take the best advantage of the
renewables that that are being built all
over we can even begin to imagine what
kind of technologies will be enabled by
better batteries it will be the first to
reach the breakthrough one thing is
certain the race is on for me it's been
fascinating to watch and track the
progress over just the last few years if
you want to see more and better
advancements including new rapid charges
and new concepts like Samsung's graphene
battery stick around for the links
they'll also be in the description below
so thanks for watching guys that was a
look at battery technology if you've
learned something new feel free to
subscribe this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]